le 7-8 sport numéro 5 sa cinquième
rendez vous hebdo de 26 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité sportive du
week-end bienvenue si vous venez nous
rejoindre sur tv fil 78 ce week end à
lyon se déroulaient les championnats de
france de taekwondo des clubs locaux y
participer j'accueille sur ce plateau
quesnel mazérois bonsoir vous êtes
compétitrices du tk des 78 l'un des
entraîneurs du club guillaume tran
bonsoir à vous et puis également présent
pour le bushido club de trappes yann
buren compétiteurs et christophe famille
entraîneur également on va parler de vos
performances à respectifs dans une
peut-être petite dizaine de minutes le
temps de retrouver anthony rech il a
rencontré un équipage et blinois qui
prépare le 4l trophy ce rendez vous
dédié aux étudiants départ prévu le 14
février
bienvenue dans ce set 8 sport du 4
février à 7,8 sport exceptionnel puisque
ce soir nous allons à la rencontre des
sportifs et nous nous trouvons dans un
lieu particulier le pré pas fort raid ce
garage dédié à la préparation des
véhicules participant au 4l trophy ce
raid solidaire long de 6000 km qui
traverse la france l'espagne et le maroc
destiné uniquement aux étudiants et qui
regroupe mille quatre cent cinquante
équipages et parmi ces mille quatre cent
cinquante équipages il y a deux saint
quentinois qui tentent leur première
aide leur premier 4l trophy il s'agit de
william ou neuf et bastien guilbaud ils
sont tous les deux avec moi bonsoir à
tous les deux mois ça va alors c'est
votre première expérience sur sur ce
raid solidaire comment on vient on peut
être au 4l trophy on entendait déjà
parler par les médias avec c'est la
seizième édition cette année donc c'est
très médiatisé et
tous les deux l'un de notre côté on en a
entendu parler on s'est concerté et puis
on en est venu comme ça voilà qu'est ce
que c'est on s'est renseignés ont fait
les premières inscriptions notre
association et puis on recherche des
sponsors et puis les parties le projet
in et quant à peu près bastien il ya un
an deux ans trois ans où ses plus
récents on entendu parlé à allah la
session de l'année dernière donc la
période de février là comme cette année
est beau fusion s'est dit ouais pourquoi
pas nous donc c'est parti on a mis deux
mois
à faire tout ce processus de réflexion
et puis vers la fin avril enfin brice
était parti quoi alors le nom de votre
équipe et un peu aussi particulier
puisque il s'agit de du team quattro
fille alors d'où ce nom d'où ça vient en
fait il ya une histoire particulière un
petit peu d origine spécifiques bien sûr
c'est pas recherché par hasard on
travaille tous les deux dans un circuit
donc d'automobiles donc on connaît pas
mal le sport mécanique et par amy donc
le mot quoi trophy notre association il
ya deux mots donc quattro à celle
véhicule qui a fait notamment des raids
comme celui qu'on va faire et le mot
trophy qui et qui fait partie du 4l
trophy est alors donc une petite
expérience de mécaniciens j'imagine
quand on quand on travaille sur un
circuit tout à fait on peut dire ça on a
vraiment les yeux rivés sur les
véhicules quand ils passent devant nous
on est bien l'absorber par par cette
petite passion et donc on en est venu
justement ça nous a amenés au 4l trophy
met les mains un petit peu dans le
cambouis faire de la mécanique au départ
on était vraiment théorique et
maintenant grâce au garage ça a pu nous
permettre d'avancer de faire notre
préparation nous mêmes et d'apprendre
énormément alors je le mentionnais tout
à l'heure ici on est dans un lieu
particulier le prépa forêt de ce garage
dédié juste au préau préparation des
véhicules pour ce 4l trophy ils vous
aident énormément ils vous ont peut-être
aussi tout a pris peut-être sur sur la
mécanique d'une 4l c'est certain le
garage prépa forêt des vraiment
spécialisé dans les 4l les 4l pour red
donc prépa 4 par aide et effectivement
ils nous ont accueillis les bras ouverts
et c'est eux qui nous ont vraiment tout
appris d'ailleurs on peut que les
remercier parce que sans eux on ne
serait pas là aujourd'hui et j'imagine
que bastien auparavant une 4l vous
n'étiez jamais monté dedans jamais monté
dedans et que j'en avais jamais idées
pour nous montrer un jour de danse
fortement c'est les voitures donc c'est
sympa quoi c'est la découverte totale de
la voiture en elle-même mais aussi de sa
mécanique puisque ça a beaucoup changé
ces dernières années il a fallu six
mètres et les mettre les mains dans le
cambouis comme on dit absolument tout à
fait d'ailleurs je crois que vous avez
encore un petit peu sur les mains non on
a un soir à peine il faut les mettre et
tous les jours et toute façon il faudra
les mettre pendant le raid c'est une
obligation pour faire les choses bien il
faut le faire je joue pas mal
heureusement parce que ça nous apprend
encore une fois énormément de choses sur
un plan mécanique y est tout autre alors
c'est une mécanique assez simple les 4
el sadate
quand même dans cette année de nos
parents nos parents
malgré tout il faut s'y habituer il faut
comprendre le système et c'est pas
forcément ça et alors je crois que vous
avez eu quelques péripéties avec le
châssis notamment jeu de votre quatre
essais ça alors on avait acheté une
première 4l
et finalement le châssis était pas très
bonnes et en il y avait les longerons
complètement troué rouillé donc c'est
les maladies des quatre ncc la rouille
et donc du coup on a dû racheter une
notre 4l mais cette fois uniquement le
châssis parce que le moteur de la
première 4è étaient ils étaient
fonctionnels et c'est là qu'on a été
contacté par réunis qui tient un garage
prépa forêt d'où on est en ce moment
même il nous a proposé un un marché donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est là et le 4l
trophy c'est évidemment l'aspect un peu
sportif mécanique mais c'est aussi
l'aspect solidaire 1 seraient des
célèbres pour ça c'est cet aspect là qui
vous a attiré particulièrement sur sur
cette course ou pas du tout alors oui
oui moi je suis en staps à orsay donc
c'est des études visite sportive donc
c'est sûr surtout le côté sportif qui
m'a attiré mais avec le côté humanitaire
si on peut joindre l'utile à l'agréable
et de votre côté william je suis en
école d'ingénieur dans le développement
durable et les nouvelles énergies et
il ya un lien un étroit lien mais quand
même un très gros lien avec le 4l trophy
qui est justement le développement
durable il ya toute une notion
d'écologie au travers du 4l trophy et
puis la notion d' humanitaires fait
aussi preuve de ce que j'avais envie de
faire cette année et donc tous alliés
nous donne vraiment une réelle envie de
participer et alors dans le coffre vous
allez embarquer beaucoup de fournitures
j'imagine des fournitures scolaires du
para médical de quelle sorte on a un peu
de tout beaucoup de scolaires puisqu'il
faut rapporter au minimum deux sacs de
sacs scolaires pour étudiants pour
jeunes écoliers qui seront distribués là
bas mais remplit donc de stylos de
trousses de classeurs tout ça on a on en
a même beaucoup plus que la demande on a
aussi du paramédical et qu'avec tout ce
qui est con presse des non périssables
donc pas de médicaments c'est trop et b
et on a aussi une partie qui est
sportive donc des sacs avec des baskets
des chartes d tout ce qui ce tricheur tu
des tee-shirts ça va être serré dans le
véhicule non entre l'antre la caisse à
outils les fournitures ça va être
compliqué de pouvoir tout mettre non en
général on peut plus rien rentré après
alors le départ c'est le 12 février au
soir pour vous c'est ça au village
départ c'est ça 14 février officielle
pour le 4l trophy à potier est pour nous
le 12 au soir donc de maurepas nous par
pur en direction de poitiers où nos
vérifications techniques selon le 13
samedi là bas très bien merci beaucoup à
tous les deux nous avoir accueillis non
dans ce lieu si particulier et bonne
route sur sur ce 4l trophy on suivra
évidemment votre course et on vous
accueillera sur le plateau de tv fils au
retour si c'est possible merci à vous
merci beaucoup avant de retrouver
wilfried sur le plateau pour le bilan
des championnats de france de taekwondo
je vous propose de nous arrêter sur ce
garage le pré pas fort raid vous l'avez
compris c'est un lieu particulier pas
comme les autres pourquoi et qu'en est
il des explications avec dix ans quand
c'est elodie moines
rémy labouize sert ses premiers boulots
à l'âge de 14 ans dans un garage pour
tondeuse il apprend sur le tas les
bricoles tout ce qui lui passe entre les
mains mobylette voiture il y a quelques
années un ami adepte du 4 l trophy le
contacter pour une réfection de moteur
et l'histoire d'amour commence
connaissaient pas forcément bien les
moteurs de 4 à elle mais j'avais les
bases d'un moteur à explosion classique
j'ai relevé le défi j'ai refait son
moteur et la refais le 4l trophy est
tombé amoureux de cette mécanique hyper
simple et depuis j'ai pas lâcher
participant au 4l trophy 2012 ils
installent sont établis dans le garage
de ses parents où il met un beau bazar
mail envie de repartir sur le raid est
toujours là en 2013 c'est alors que le
garage prépa for red devient une
évidence vente de pièces pour ce
véhicule mythique récupération d'anciens
châssis une préparation bien spécifique
pour les participants le gros avantage
qu'on a c'est que ce sont vraiment les
équipages qui prépare la voiture à
proprement dit on leur explique comment
faire et on leur donne un coup de main
s'il faut et ils font tout eux-mêmes
quasiment sur la voiture et donc on sait
de fierté en partant d'avoir un véhicule
qu'ils ont fait leurs preuves dans ce
garage est particulière un autre titre
sous les capots se cache une
mécanicienne c'est pas toujours évident
se moque un peu de moi quand je faisais
petite question rémy c'est quoi ce truc
là ça va c'est pas évident mais j'ai
vraiment beaucoup appris et c'est vrai
que c'est enfin c'est vrai que c'est
super intéressant par exemple votre
office dépanner des mecs c'était un peu
ça intéresse
victime de son succès prépa forêt de
refusent de plus en plus d'équipages
pour une préparation complète du
véhicule le garage réclame une centaine
d'euros par mois
et nous poursuivons donc cette édition
du 7 8 sport en plateau à présent ce 4
février avec les participants au
championnat de france de taekwondo
c'était ce week end à lyon je vous
représente nous inviter si vous n'étiez
pas avec nous au début de cette édition
canal maizeroi et guillaume tran donc du
t4 des 78 yens lurel et christophe
famille du bushido club de trappes
félicitations à tous les quatre parce
que vous avez obtenu de bons résultats
lors de cette compétition quel est le
troisième en plus de 73 kg et ian burel
également 3e mais chez les hommes en
moins de 81 kg tout à fait rond se sont
passés vos combats respectifs alors
plutôt bien malgré qu'il ait perdu en
demi-finale j'ai fait un premier combat
face une alsacienne est mon deuxième
face à anne caroline graffe
vice-championne olympique vous êtes dans
les objectifs
des parce que vous étiez fixés au moins
de monter sur le podium voilà de
remonter encore une fois sur le podium
mais de faire mieux encore on verra
qu'en pense dans des entraîneurs des
responsables du club sur sa performance
donc avec les peu moins de moins qu on a
par rapport à l'équipe de france on
aurait pas comme a donné un bon
résultats
lorsqu'elle est quand même tombé contre
la vice championne olympique caroline
graffe avec
c'est pas évident de on ne peut pas
espérer gagner contre elle de prendre de
l'expérience face à des adversaires de
ce niveau au moment où vous entendez
justement que vous allez affronter la
vice championne olympique vous vous
dites quoi c'est pas de bol non j'étais
contente j'étais content de ses intérêts
supplémentaires c'est un défi parce que
depuis quasiment
quatre ans voire cinq ans je perds
toujours en demi finale face à anne
chorégraphe donc j'étais contente de la
retrouver et de pouvoir encore combattre
la saed en demi-finale et à quel moment
vous avez prévu de vous imposer face à
elle c'est prévu un toujours toujours
rêvé un jour j'y arriverai gester eliane
de votre côté pour le bushido club
comment se sont passés vos différentes
rencontres avant cette troisième place
alors moi j'ai eu quatre combats en tout
donc trois combats et plus cela ma demi
finale donc j'ai eu un début difficile
puisque lors de mon premier combat
j'étais mené 8,1 au premier rang fin du
premier round 8 1 donc il a fallu se
ressaisir et et repartir de l'avant donc
j'ai gagné finalement le combat je crois
de 17 à 8 donc les coaches angus ont su
trouver les mots pour me remettre sur la
route et après j'ai continué sur un
deuxième tour qui était assez facile un
troisième tour toujours critique puisque
c'est le combat à gagner pour la
médaille le quart de finale c'est là
qu'il ya le plus de pression peut-être
oui sur ouï oui parce que les premiers
tours on peut gagner les deux premiers
mais si on perd le troisième c'est comme
si on avait perdu dès le premier tour en
fait donc le combat est passée et là
il ya eu donc la qualification et le
combat pour la demi-finale où j'ai
rencontré
tenant du titre mamedy doucara et là je
crois que j'ai perdu mais c'est parce
que j'ai pas cru je n'ai pas cru en mes
chances j'aurais dû
plus me lâcher c'est les combats c'est
pour ça qu'on s'entraîne c'est pour ce
type de combat et malheureusement le
jour j j'ai pas eu si j'ai pas su saisir
ma chance et je crois que bon c'est
toujours après coup qu'on réalise mon
coach en parlera mieux que moi mais qu'
on tenait quelque chose la victoire elle
était là et parfois faut croire en ses
chances et justement pas se mettre de
barrières face à des athlètes qui sont
des athlètes confirmés qui s'entraînent
dans le cadre de l'insep mais pour moi
c'est pas c'est pas un critère suffisant
tout est possible on est en phase d'être
humain et c'est nous qui nous mettons
des barea partage alors cette analyse
c'était une barrière psychologique
c'est en disant je suis bien à bella
tout dire je veux dire par rapport à ce
matin et ce concernant son combat tout
madame un recul à appréhender
l'événement effectivement je crois que
pour le coup il est résulté concernant
sa performance concernant son état
d'esprit et comme le dit moins bon
certes mais dit il est un champion du
monde s'il est il était multiple
champion de france et deux catégories
donc c'est effectivement gérer
l'événement plus le statut d'individu en
face c'est pas forcément évident mais
comme il le dit lui même c'est ce
n'était pas faute de préparation c'était
plus faute ce moment de sa session cette
opportunité pour pouvoir enfin passer un
cap face à la tête de ce type que ce
soit pour vous ou pour vous la
différence est la même quand on
contraint athlètes confirmés qui
s'entraîne au quotidien professionnel il
manque un déclic ça se fait dans la tête
ce n'est pas
disons que ce qui est important quand on
est athlète de haut niveau c'est se
mettre dans les conduits conditions
optimum de la coopération n'est pas
simplement physique n'est pas ce moment
la plus importante et surtout
psychologiquement c'est à partir non pas
dans ce type de compétition on sait déjà
que la règle de base c'est une copie
scientologie au chaos donc on se prépare
on prépare donc on a toutes les chances
pour éviter justement c'était non mais
aussi le mois le pouvoir justement ces
opportunités 30 des risques se mettre en
danger pour pouvoir c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre l'athlète de sportifs
lambda et tous ces champions justement
savoir vous lui avez dit quoi lors du
premier combat lorsqu'il était mené
autant de points d'écart pour qu'il
revienne dans la compétition j'ai failli
on peut le dire à la télé avec vos mots
à vous mais en imaginant qu'il est all
que ce que je vais rappeler simplement
c'est que c'est que lui-même c'est un
incident a été un instrument de l'insep
certes il a plus depuis quelque temps
qu'il a fait partie le signalement donné
deux en tant que partie d'entraînement
pour le pour l'équipe de france qu'il a
déjà côtoyé même dit en interne qui va
les qualités et que tout le monde sait
même dans minutes et compte d'autres et
tout le monde est toujours plus ou moins
surpris de voir ryan n'est pas d'aider
fois s'exprimer comme ils devraient le
faire donc pour le coup c'est ce que je
veux rappeler c'est simplement qu'il
était la qualité en tant qu'individu et
en tant qu'homme et en tant qu'athlète
et comment les décrets et qu'il arrive à
aligner les deux pour pouvoir et ben
justement ne pas passer à côté de
l'événement et il a repris confiance et
donc cette troisième place cannell
j'aimerais juste un bond par rapport à
votre frère que s'est il passé et s'est
incliné en quart de finale face au futur
champion ensuite un de france des des
plus de 87 kg c'est maxime du car il est
déçu il est comme on est un peu déçu
quand même par rapport à ça mais il dit
par rapport à l'entraînement qu'il a eue
c'est vrai que là cela est plus un
entraînement je pense qu'il aurait fait
encore un meilleur combat meilleur
combat et là il a perdu avec un écart de
trois points petite défaite voilà malgré
taux effectivement ça doit être après
ensuite difficile comment vous allez
leur mobilisés par exemple il est pas là
avec nous ce soir peut-être qu'il écoute
alors juste mémoire vous lui diriez quoi
pour qu'il se remette dans la
compétition pleinement sans sans trop se
stresser ou être abattus par ce résultat
me la mer des choses c'est apporter de
meilleures dynamiques concernés au sein
du club au sein du département pour
établir à un échange entre tra péter
galison de 18 afin de motiver les
athlètes c'est par sept
par cette ambiance qui va pouvoir cette
énergie qui va pouvoir motiver mathias
notre athlète et
me permettre au département de devenir
un poids au sein de la région nous avons
deux clubs de saint quentin en yvelines
deux clubs du département des yvelines
vous travaillez ensemble justement aussi
parce que vous étiez présent chacun pour
votre club sur ce tournoi mais est ce
qu'il ya des passerelles entre les deux
clubs ponctuellement
une ranvin organisé récemment un stage
départemental où on a pu pratiquer des
oppositions entre combattants des
différents clubs forcément j'ai posé la
question à athènes mais je vais leur
poser maintenant parce que je sais
qu'elle va leur plaire qui domine pour
l'instant entre les deux clubs photos
nettes
rap
mais pour défendre les couleurs vous
allez dire que c'est pour dire on vient
de la même école et
comment dire nous on est derrière on
commence à mettre d'autres à tête en
place et que si jamais ils baissent les
bras ou
la place leur place il ya une rivalité
saine entre les deux qui s'installe et
il faut pas oublier que les deux clubs
sont assez liés puisque il ya un
créateur comment on peut dire à
l'origine dans le taekwondo au niveau de
la ville de ville nouvelle de saint
quentin c'est jean claude lebon qui
publie aujourd'hui qualité voilà qui a
été notre maître ainsi qu'aux
professeurs aujourd'hui sur tkd 78 de
parler donc des championnats de france
qui se sont déroulés à lyon il y aura
des mondiaux du 15 au 19 mai vous en
rêvez
j'aurais bien voulu les faire mais bon
le vrai pour chacun d'entre vous ce sera
quoi la suite pour vous dans la dans la
compétition dans les prochains mois dans
les prochains mois ce serait si je suis
qualifié avec l'équipe de france serait
l'open international de belgique j'avais
fait une classe 2e l'an dernier j'avais
perdu contre
une norvégienne qui est partie audio si
je peux refaire la même chose je serai
contente maintenant tout se passe
dimanche en sélection vous souhaite donc
bonne chance et pour vous au moins je
suis un peu plus âgés donc mon avenir
sportif dépendra de mon état de forme
est monté à 1 ou 2 open et d'ici la fin
de l'année on est en train de voir des
partenariats avec deux athlètes pour
pour travailler peut-être faire avancer
me faire avancer mais aussi faire
avancer tout tout tout la signer là les
générations suivantes au sein du club de
trappes déchets dont club de trappes tkd
78 félicitations donc à trouver deux
processions d'idiomes félicitations donc
à vos deux clubs merci d'être venu sur
le plateau ce forme toujours avant de
passer aux résultats du week end je vous
propose de découvrir un portrait à
présent elle s'appelle mélissa mahut
elle a 14 ans et vous allez voir qu'elle
se débrouille plutôt bien en baseball
elle pourrait même poursuivre sa
carrière assez rapidement du côté des
états unis
quand j'ai commencé j'avais les moins
bien mais après j'ai grandi après
c'était plus à
elle ne savait pas encore lire que tenir
là bas tu étais naturel à 14 ans mélissa
mahieu collectionne les titres de
meilleure lanceuse et de mvp meilleure
joueuse du championnat
sélectionné en équipe de france ne
softball et de baseball depuis un an
capitaine de son équipe aux cougars la
jeune minime antenne n'a pas atteint ce
niveau par hasard mélissa va essayer
d'apprendre le geste le plus
consciencieusement possible le répéter à
l'infini pour pouvoir s'améliorer
maintenant ce n'est plus
sur une globalité de jeu qu'elle a à
prendre c'est sur des points de détail
et c'est pour ça qu'il lui faut des des
coaches qui soit du niveau national pour
pouvoir construire son jeu depuis
quelques mois les plus grandes
fédérations étrangères lui font les yeux
doux en octobre dernier elle est invitée
à découvrir le baseball féminin japonais
dans quelques jours la lanceuse des
cougars va s'envoler pour cuba pour
participer à un stage avec la sélection
nationale canadienne en vue des
championnats du monde 2014 mais elle
reste les pieds sur terre et ne compte
pas abandonner son club formateur pour
autant j'aimerais bien pouvoir jouer
jusqu'à 18 ans en france et après
pouvoir partir à l'étranger dans une
université
mais pour l'instant je me débrouille
j'arrive à bien faire les dom et il ya
des moments où ça devient compliqué il
faut pouvoir faire louper des
entraînements
c'est quoi mon école qui reste
prioritaire
malheureusement pour le club saint
quentinois la réglementation ne permet
pas aux filles de jouer avec les garçons
après l'âge de 15 ans seul le softball
leur est ouvert mais mélissa a déjà fait
son choix
l'essentiel du week end l'essentiel des
résultats sport à présent avec quelques
tableaux qui vont s'afficher tout
d'abord du handball féminin et vous
allez le voir montini s'est imposé à
domicile dans le cadre de la 13e journée
de nationale 2 31 22 large victoire
acquise dl la mi temps une victoire qui
leur permet de s'accrocher à cette
cinquième place au général le podium est
encore loin le premier le havre compte
neuf points à d'avançon passe aux bases
qui était une fois n'est pas coutume et
ses trappes chez les hommes qui
l'emportent alors que le chesnay
versailles en féminines s'inclinent une
défaite sur le fil pour les féminines
d'ailleurs est ce qui nous donne tout
d'abord au classement en ce qui concerne
l'équipe féminine l'a toujours la
première place pour les féminines vous
l'avez vu juste auparavant et puis du
côté des hommes en revanche les
trappistes se retrouve 13e il grappille
quelques points ils sont toujours en
position de relégable et plus juste une
précision concernant les féminines de
l'entente le chesnay versailles elle se
laisse rattraper en ce moment par à
leurs adversaires directs attention à
cette seconde partie de championnat donc
du tennis de table féminin par équipe
vous allez le voir également l'entente
voisin saint-arnoult à qu'ils
l'emportent alors qu'elle en cours ne
peut s imposer sur le terrain de la
trinité sport ce qui au classement place
les deux clubs locaux sur le podium
enfin un tout dernier à tableau en rugby
12e journée de 3e division fédérale
plaisir s'incline face au leader
beauvais match difficile pour l'équipe
locale à domicile et au classement
beauvais qui reste donc toujours premier
plaisir n'est que 5e mais peut espérer à
présent monter sur le podium en foot us
les templiers version cadets cependant
viennent de débuter leur saison à une
marche du titre la saison passée ils se
disent plus motivé que jamais le résumé
de la rencontre de samedi face à
asnières
objectif numéro un champion de france
objectif clair pour les templiers
d'elancourt pas de place au doute au
sein de la formation des cadets
finalistes de conférence l'an passé et
pourtant des premières minutes
hésitantes à l'image de se lancer et un
receveur à la peine
quelques minutes plus tard même action
précision toujours hasardeuses
les molosses d'asnières se montre plus
efficace et ne manque pas l'occasion
d'ouvrir le score sur cette course d'une
vingtaine de yard
la conversion est ratée 6 à 0 pour les
représentants des hauts-de-seine
loin d'être démobilisé les jeunes
templiers repartent au contact et sur
cette troisième tentative passe la ligne
d'en-but au forceps
là aussi à la conversion se solde sur un
échec
nouvelle phase offensive quelques
minutes plus tard et le quarterback sauf
une course de plus de 50 yards 12,6 pour
elle en cours
on pense les visiteurs assommés mais ils
réussiront à recoller au score lors de
la seconde période 12 partout score
final
nous sommes très soudés nous restons de
famille le but de des templiers c'est de
rester une famille nous sommes poussés
vers la victoire vers ce titre de
champion de france qui nous a échappé
derrière prochain match sur le terrain
des mureaux le 23 février
à noter que l'équipe junior s'est imposé
le dimanche face aux corsaires d'evry 29
à 6 début des championnats du des
seniors programmé le 16 février sur le
terrain des spartiates d'amiens il
faudra attendre la semaine prochaine
pour voir évoluer et donc les templiers
sur leur terrain pour conclure un mot
sur le vendée globe c'est habituel avec
tanguy de lamotte le skipper versailles
et qui poursuit son aventure solitaire
en pleine mer quelques nouvelles sur le
plan sportif déjà il est toujours la 11e
place à quelques 2600 milles des sables
d'olonne il a subi un choc dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche il a non seulement
casser le safran tribord et entraîné
également une voie d'eau sur son bateau
mais pour autant il reste confiant mais
ça je postais hier justement sur son
twitter officiel je suis au ralenti mais
pas stoppée on le connaît on sait qu'il
garde forcément espoir et puis quelques
heures auparavant juste avant cet
incident sur son bateau il avait posté
une vidéo vous la voyez actuellement à
l'image il s'exprimait à l'attention de
david beckham le skipper rappelons le
tout d'abord est engagée pour
l'association initiative coeur 12
enfants malades du coeur vont être
opérés grâce aux fonds récoltés par sa
participation est dorénavant ils
souhaitent que david beckham se joignent
à lui vous le savez le joueur du psg a
décidé de donner son un salaire à des
associations et pourquoi pas initiative
coeur voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition du suite ce sport la semaine
prochaine nouveaux points en 26 minutes
pour l'essentiel du sport le 7-8 sport
sur téléfilm